foreign
it's scary stuff and the News likes to
scare us that's how they get us to pay
attention and I covered this on the Ken
Coleman show today uh Zoom
the uh the Wonder kid of the pandemic
everybody was zooming you know I was
like hey how did Skype not get on that
they just they missed the boat man I
don't know how Skype missed it it was
like Zoom was kind of new and a couple
people started talking about it and so
Zoom blew up in a good way they were the
darling of the tech industry because
everybody was zooming Zoom this Zoom
that zoom zoom zoom and so they went
zoom zoom too many zooms so many zooms
feel like I used Too Many there probably
three Mazda commercials exactly just
three too many but nonetheless announced
uh that they laid off 1300 employees or
15 of its Workforce this is from CEO
Eric Juan announced last week to staff
now he went on to say something that
I've seen in the news
feels like nine out of ten times when we
see layoffs announced well we staffed up
and we overstaffed
and now the economy's changed the
Outlook has changed and we gotta let
some people go I'm really sorry it's my
fault now that's been the general
message and that's what he said as well
um he took responsibility said he was
going to show accountability
by reducing his salary for the coming
fiscal year by 98 as well as foregoing
his 2023 corporate bonus
uh members of zoom's executive
leadership team will also jump in and
reduce their base salaries by 20 for the
year and forfeit their corporate bonuses
too his base salary last year was 301
731 dollars just to give you some
context
um and um he offered support to those
they had to lay off by including up to
16 week salary and Health Care coverage
now I'm sure he got criticized because
that's what people do
I thought this was a classy move
um in that saying you know what I'm
going to penalize myself as well I'm
sure he's made millions of dollars
potentially in stock obviously uh but
still it's a good move but I know he was
widely lampooned by people who think
well you're the rich guy so I don't know
if they want a pound of Flesh
a gallon of his own blood what do they
want what's in that I think they really
want him to just resign and why because
they're feeling pain and therefore
everyone needs to feel pain well believe
me he's feeling pain his pain is
relative to their pain but he's feeling
pain uh it's not fun for a CEO to lay
off a bunch of people we're seeing this
across the board with big tech companies
and the truth is these are all mostly
public publicly traded companies so
they're shareholders and so at the end
of the day like it or not that's how
this runs is you got to keep the
shareholders hey happy at the end of the
day Disney did it Disney laid off 7 000
workers last week you're probably
following this story I know you're a big
Disney guy you lost how you talk about
on the Ken Coleman show thank you George
moments ago watching Bob Iger uh former
CEO comes back and announces a
restructure lays off seven thousand
people and pointedly says in his press
release
we've got to cut costs and fix the stock
price and after hours trading the stock
price jumps
and again this is what you will be at a
large public company you will be a
number on a spreadsheet because Disney's
obviously struggling from a business
standpoint but they're not you know
they're not gonna they're not gonna have
problems keeping things open
uh but I'll tell you the lesson about
Disney that I'm gonna I'm gonna take
this away from Big corporate news and
I'm going to give a quick lesson
about authenticity and winning in your
professional life
when Disney stopped being about kids
having fun
and Fantasyland and all the wonderful
smiles and parents being happy because
kiddos are happy
and they started getting involved in
pushing the social agendas
when ESPN stopped talking about sports
and started getting into things outside
of sports their numbers are hurting I'm
not saying they're right or wrong for
doing it I'm simply saying the business
cases stick to who you are as a business
don't try to be cute with who you are as
a person who are you authentically uh
who are you as a business and trying to
get cool trying to follow the uh the
waves of culture you'll get burned is my
point that's the bigger lesson yeah so
there you go even from the zoom story
their stock jumped 10 after the layoff
well of course because the investors say
yay you cut expenses but what about all
those people I appreciate the 16 weeks
of salary yeah when the healthcare did
you see Google's layoffs they're perks I
mean when they left I was like these
people could retire today just off of
them but that was still as you know wow
Google just laying people the way they
did it was not ridiculous cool so a lot
of Leadership Lessons to be learned here
be careful